[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es endlich
die gewünschte regenbogen torte die habt
ihr euch schon extrem lange gewünscht
und letztens kurz bevor ich einkaufen
bei kaufland habe ich noch schnell einen
fragen sticker bei instagram gemacht um
euch zu fragen was möchtet ihr
eigentlich soll die aufwendig sein soll
man von außen sehen dass es einen
regenbogen
dort ist und ihr habt eigentlich fast
einstimmig entschieden dass sie von
außen nicht erkennbar sein soll das
heißt außen wird sie weist werden und
vielleicht ein paar streusel mit
reinigen das entscheide ich spontan
und innen dann kunterbunt und sie soll
ohne von ganz sein und komplett anfänger
freundlich und genau so mache ich das
auch
habt ihr die ganzen zutaten eingekauft
und ich lege direkt los mit dem teig das
muss jetzt natürlich ein heller teig
sein wir färben nämlich gleich schön ein
und ich mache heute in sogenannten
wunder kuchen da von dem wir uns ja die
habe ich jetzt hier schon in der
rührschüssel einer küchenmaschine und
gebt da zucker und vanille mit dazu das
schlagen wir dann richtig schön hey
cremig das dauert so ungefähr vier bis
maximal fünf minuten
[Musik]
in die hell cremige masse geben wir dann
apfelsaft und rapsöl könntet auch
sonnenburg öl verwenden und generell
findet ihr alle genauen mengenangaben
hier unten in der video beschreibung und
jetzt mache ich mich an die trockenen
zutaten da haben wir mehl und backpulver
das einmal vor ort miteinander verrühren
dann verbindet sich das bisher im teig
und jetzt in einem schwung mit zur masse
7 das ist ganz wichtig gibt das einmal
komplett rein und dann nur ganz kurz
unter rühren bis es sich verbunden hat
und dann können wir den teig auch schon
einfärben
[Musik]
und den fertigen teig dann ganz einfach
durch sechs teilnahme ist nimmt euch
ausreichend große schüsseln und eine
suppenkelle oder irgendwas
vergleichbares damit ihr immer die
gleiche menge habt und anschließend mit
gel farben das ist das beste weil die
flüssigen farben würden den teig die
konsistenz des teigs verändern und mit
gel farben macht ihr einfach nichts
falsch gebt ihr dann da rein in
regenbogenfarben ich habe jetzt genommen
blau violett grün rot gelb und orange
orange hat sich als farbe so nicht da
deswegen er mischt einfach gelb und rot
und dann bekommt ihr orange und jetzt
fange ich an zu hören und dann mit magic
dann verwandelt sich der teig und jetzt
geht es ans auspacken wir haben jetzt
hier sechs bilden insgesamt und da wir
alle sechs einzeln backen habe ich mir
gedacht ich mache jetzt die torte etwas
kleiner und zwar mit einem durchmesser
von 20 cm hier auch meinen springform
ihr könnt auch torten ringe nimmt zum
beispiel und dann kann ich eben immer
zwei auf einmal backen weil es ist nicht
gut für den teig wenn er sehr lange
steht also er sollte schon zügig weiter
verarbeitet werden also gebacken werden
aber sobald ich mich jetzt und dann ist
es auch gar kein thema schiebt immer
eins nach dem anderen rein
beziehungsweise nummer zwei so und ich
fange damit grün und lila und dann backe
ich die bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze
wichtig immerhin ofen vorheizen für
circa 15 minuten länger brauchen sie
auch nicht
[Musik]
während die böden abkühlen machen wir
jetzt die frische creme und dafür
schlage ich vorab sahnesteif das
funktioniert am besten wenn die sahne
ganz kalt ist last ein bisschen sahne
fest ein riesen und dann gibt er das
kurz an die seite und bevor in die
anderen zutaten miteinander das ist ja
einmal mascarpone dann nehme ich doch
quark mit dazu das gibt so ein bisschen
leichtigkeit natürlich puderzucker für
die süße und für die frische zitronen
schein abrieb dann nimmt dir am besten
eine bio zitrone
[Musik]
das habe ich jetzt auch nur kurz
verrührt gebet so ein bisschen sand fest
mit dazu bei quark eben nicht so fest
ist mascarpone bräuchte prinzipiell gar
kein seiner fest aber weil wir im quark
haben mache ich das jetzt noch mal zur
sicherheit für das gut um und dann mit
ganz viel liebe mit einem teils aber ihr
kennt einmal die sahne unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt ist die creme fertig und ihr könnt
sie jetzt entweder einfach so drauf
spritzen oder ihr fühlt sie euch in
einen spritzbeutel das mache ich so
damit ich überall immer gleich viel
creme habt können das natürlich auch
einschätzen das ist gar kein problem und
damit jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen
mehr fruchtigkeit mit rein kommt und es
trotzdem hell bleibt nehme ich aprikosen
konfitüre
ich habe sie kurz in der mikrowelle
erwärmt dann wird sie richtig schön
flüssig und jetzt verfahren einfach so
dass ihr den boden mit der aprikosen
konfitüre drängt mit der creme füllt bis
ihrem letzten boden angekommen seid und
dann schließt er mit creme ab und dann
zeige ich euch wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich alles komplett befüllt
und eingestrichen und die oberste
schicht einmal mit der sahne creme
versiegeln damit eben der letzte boden
auch nicht austrocknen jetzt könnt ihr
die torte für eine halbe stunde kühl
fall dass bei euch in der küche
irgendwie total warm sein sollte ich
muss es jetzt nicht weil die creme ist
schon sehr fest und wir haben jetzt
zügig gearbeitet daher entferne ich
jetzt den tortenring das macht ihr
normalerweise ja mit dem backform löser
mit dem kurzen das klassische das kennt
ihr das klappt jetzt nicht weil die
torte ist schon ziemlich hoch ich zeige
euch auch später sonderanstalt technik
die ich für mich entwickelt habe und die
werdet ihr jetzt einmal mit dem
tortenring messer xxl befreien
das ist tatsächlich ganz neu und ich
benutze ist jetzt auch in dem video zum
ersten mal daher einmal am rand seine
werbe stimme meldet sich so einmal
vorsichtig hier am rand rhein mit der
klammer hinten dran dann am rand entlang
fahren
das tolle ist dass ich eben jetzt gerade
so in dieser position bin mit unseren
herstellern dass ich neue produkte
entwickler dass ich die realisieren kann
und die eben dann bei uns im online shop
anbieten kann und das ist eben eines der
produkte ihr habt gerade auch schon was
andere gesehen aber das zeige ich euch
so in den nächsten videos nach und nach
zu beschränken
ja es ist natürlich eine neuheit ja ihr
werdet das tatsächlich nicht finden also
und so und jetzt einmal den
trocken bin vorsichtig entfernen und da
darf jetzt auch nichts
perfekt also da ist jetzt auch nichts
gerissen und jetzt nehmen wir uns die
restliche grebe ich finde es eigentlich
so schon megaschön also nikkei charakter
irgendwie aber machen so weil ihr
wolltet jetzt eine helle außenhülle
creme märz gesagt man soll eigentlich
nicht sehen dass ich einen ring punkt
heute darunter versteckt daher einmal
rundherum einstreichen
das ist echt cool aus also wer jetzt
keine lust mehr hat der lässt es so ich
will
[Musik]
mit der restlichen creme dekoriere ich
jetzt noch die oberfläche der torte und
ich habe euch tatsächlich wieder mal auf
instagram gefragt ich habe diese leute
eigentlich nur mit euch kreiert ob ich
außen irgendwas buntes irgendwie
streusel oder so etwas buntes doch
drüberstreuen soll oder ob ich gar
nichts machen soll dann ist die komplett
weiß oder ob ich weiß zu streuseln
nehmen und der großteil hat tatsächlich
gesagt lasst sie außen weiß damit auch
das geburtstagskind eventuell total
überrascht ist was da auf einmal für
bunte farben rauskommt und mir gefällt
es auch richtig gut muss ich sagen ich
hab's jetzt komplett weiß gelassen und
ich schreibe euch auch die ganz genauen
mengenangaben wie immer unten in die
video beschreibung nachher seht ja auch
noch wie ich die torte anschneiden
diese hohen trocken- und dann lassen wir
sie uns schmecken und verteilen auf
jeden fall den rest hat leider keinen
geburtstag wünsche ich jetzt ganz viel
freude beim nachmachen schreibt mir
unbedingt in die kommentare was ihr euch
als nächstes wünscht und dann machen wir
das nach hansa jeden fall bis zum
nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]